Yet, another early example of clinical decisions support was Internists,
developed starting in 1974 at the University of Pittsburgh by Dr. Jack Myers,
an internal medicine physician,
and Dr. Harry E. Pople,
a computer scientist and pioneer in artificial intelligence.
Health Informatics is often the first place the new computer science technique appears,
but according to Volume 64 of the Encyclopedia of Library and Information Science,
"Applying abduction to artificial intelligence problems began with
Harry Pople and his system, internist."
In 1985, book, Logic of Discovery and Diagnosis in Medicine,
describes the program as,
"an AI partial simulation of Dr. Myers
clinical reasoning using his own internal knowledge base".
The goal of internists was to make
the appropriate diagnosis in a given clinical situation.
In that same book,
Dr. Pople describes the methods used and I will summarize his chapter here.
He explains why a Belgian approach or a branching logic,
essentially a network approach that starts with a presenting complaint, as shown here,
is inadequate to deal with the real world of clinical diagnoses where
new or conflicting data may arrive too late to assist with an interim decision,
and it may even arrive in random order.
Internist contained a knowledge-base consisting of some 500 disease entities,
organized into categories by disease system,
and there are over 3000 clinical manifestations.
This diagram of liver diseases and their related conditions and
manifestations illustrates these relationships,
and is from a chapter by Dr. Pople in the 1982 book,
Artificial Intelligence in Medicine.
You can see that each disease entity has a corresponding list of manifestations,
weighted on a scale of one to five,
based on the frequency of their occurrence in that disease.
Inversely, a scale of zero to five reflected
the strength of the association of manifestations to diseases.
Finally, there was a representation of causal,
temporal, and other relationships among entities.
This structure is in many ways,
suggestive of a SNOMED whose predecessor, SNOP,
was by then an operation at NIH but I don't know if the Internist team was aware of that.
Internists ranked disease entities that explain any or all of a patients findings,
reflecting their goodness of fit to the data.
It then formulated questions for the physician,
as shown here, to discriminate among the equally-ranked entities.
In this example, the computer is considering the diagnosis of
acute Disseminated Intravascular Coagulopathy or DIC,
a dangerous, potentially life-threatening
condition in which blood clots form in the small blood vessels.
Much like an attending physician might do on rounds with physicians in training,
it is asking for the results of
the pertinent laboratory tests to confirm or rule out the diagnosis.
Once a diagnosis was considered identified,
it was added to the patient's problem list.
Its manifestations were considered accounted for,
and the process repeated.
While Internists worked, in complex cases,
they are often considered inappropriate possibilities and
wasted clinician's time answering questions with respect to that.
To overcome this, Internist-II used the heuristic that recognize that
certain manifestations are distinctly
characteristic of a disease or category of diseases.
Jaundice, which is prominent in this diagram we just saw,
is highly suggestive of
liver disease so the initial focus in a patient with this symptom,
should be on this disease category as it
would be if a physician were making the diagnosis.
Internist-II also introduced a multi problem generator.
Essentially, a search process beginning globally with health problems as shown here.
It terminated when at least one problem hypothesis accounted for all clinical findings.
However, that hypothesis might or might not specify specific diseases.
If there were sufficient cues in the data,
further hypothesis reduction could reduce the possibilities to specific problems.
Finally, if further reduced the problem list by exploiting its database of causal,
temporal, and other relationships,
yet another process, analogous to what actual physicians do.